what we're going to do in this video is
give ourselves some practice in the
first step of you substitution which is
often the most difficult for those who
are first learning it and that's
recognizing when you substitution is
appropriate and then defining and
appropriate you so let's just start with
an example here so let's say we want to
take the indefinite integral of 2x plus
1 times the square root of x squared
plus X DX does u substitution apply here
and if it does how would you define that
you pause the video and try to think
about that well we just have to remind
ourselves that the U that u substitution
is really trying to undo the chain rule
if we remind ourselves what the chain
rule tells us it says look if we have a
composite function let's say F of G of X
F of G of X and we take the derivative
of that with respect to X that that is
going to be equal to the derivative of
the outside function with respect to the
inside function so f prime of G of X
times the derivative of the inside
function times the derivative of the
inside function and so u substitution is
all about well do we see a pattern like
that inside the integral do we see a
potential inside function a G of X where
I see its derivative being multiplied
well we see that over here if I look at
x squared plus X if I make that the U
what's the derivative of that well the
derivative of x squared plus X is 2x
plus 1 so we should make that
substitution if we say u is equal to x
squared plus X then we could say D u DX
the derivative of U with respect to X is
equal to 2x plus 1 if we treat our
differentials like variables or numbers
we can multiply both sides by DX which
is a little bit of hand wavy mathematics
but it's appropriate here so we could
say 2x plus 1 times DX and now what's
really interesting is here is we have
our u right over there and notice we
have our 2x plus 1
DX in fact it's not conventional to see
an integral rewritten the way I'm about
to write it but I will I could rewrite
this integral you should really view
this is the product of three things
oftentimes people just view the DX is
somehow part of the integral operator
but you could rearrange it this would
actually be legitimate you could say the
integral of the square root of x squared
plus x times 2x plus 1 DX and if you
wanted to be really clear you could even
put all of those things in parenthesis
or something like that and so here this
is our U and this right over here is our
D U and so we could rewrite this as
being equal to the integral of the
square root of U because x squared plus
X is U times D U which is much easier to
evaluate if you are still confused there
you might recognize it if I rewrite this
as u to the one-half power because now
we could just use the reverse power rule
to evaluate this and then we would have
to undo the substitution once we figure
out what this antiderivative is we then
would then reverse substitute the X
expression back in for the U